[Music]
recently I released a video that ranked
the Marvel movies from best to worst it
was a monumental task that required me
to watch all of the MCU films in
chronological order twice to get a true
idea of their standing
having seen infinity war and then
rewatching door Ragnarok with the pre
knowledge of how it lays into continuity
there were several similarities with
Thanos that I noticed in regards to the
initial invasion across the cosmos by
Odin and Heller
having scoured the internet I found that
several other Marvel fans had noticed
these similarities too and had drawn
conclusions as to what happened when
Odin originally waged war against the
galaxy and whilst the theories have not
been confirmed by the creators they make
a hell of a lot of sense throughout this
video I will be discussing those fan
theories and my own to highlight why I
think old initially attempted to use the
Infinity stones to conquer the universe
but unlike Thanos he was unable to
commit fully to the task there will be
huge spoilers here for infinity war and
Thor Ragnarok so if you haven't seen
those two films then I highly recommend
that you give this a Miss for now
without the way I'm definition and this
is my infinity war Odin fan throughout
Thor Ragnarok we get confirmation that
prior to Thor's birth his father Odin
was a violent and evil Conqueror with
the help of his daughter Heller
Odin ravaged the universe and waged war
on all who opposed him we are given the
backstory that at some point Odin had a
change of heart and decided to lock
Heller away in hell until his demise the
following by our editor blew bonus
discusses the theory in folding
years and years ago old and learned
about the Infinity stones through his
father Paul who was responsible for
taking the reality stone from the Dark
Elves after his death an old and
subsequent rise to power he with hella
outside began conquering all the realms
in order to locate and claim the stones
Eldon found the space stone first and
this allowed old in Anna's armies to
travel between realms and conquer them
quickly during this he commissioned his
forces to create a device that would
allow him to control all of the stones
at will the Infinity Gauntlet they
created the mold for it and gave one
casting as a test fit for olden complete
with fake stones to give olden an idea
of the grandeur the finish brought it
however at this time he discovered the
whereabouts of this old stone and what
was required of him to get it he'd have
to sacrifice that which he loved most
which at the time was hella he found he
couldn't do it and in that moment golden
stop being a conqueror and started being
a king hella didn't understand this
change of heart she knew what the
Infinity stones were because Odin
specifically told her and that's why
they were conquering all of the realms
hella believed that power was more
important than anything else so she and
Holden fought and when Odin won he
imprisoned her in hell as hell isn't
meant for the living this unnatural
banishment may have caused the laws of
life to break and be the reason that the
prophecy of Ragnarok was a she did Odin
then put the fake gauntlet in his
treasure room as a reminder of both what
he'd done and what he'd lost he swore
that he would protect all that he had
conquered thus Odin became Odin
all-father protector of the nine realms
Nadav Eliade decommission the gauntlet
mold and old and hid the space stone on
Midgard Odin almost definitely knew
where the reality stone was because
Odin's father had it at one time and if
this fan theory is true then he
definitely knew where the soul stone was
he might have known where the power
stone was and he probably didn't know
the time stone was already on Midgard
otherwise he likely wouldn't have risk
two stones being in the same
place at the same time when Danis
arrived on the scene and went to have
Odin's forces forge of control for the
stones they used their previous
knowledge of Odin's gauntlet to make one
for Thanos if this theory were true then
it explains how and why Odin was
previously a conqueror and why he
changed it would also explain why
there's a fake Infinity Gauntlet in
Odin's treasure room how Helen knows
it's fake how Helen knows what the
tesseract is why Odin and Halla four and
white Alice's Infinity Gauntlet is
basically the same as the fake Cortlandt
had as god this is the only real
substantial conclusion that one can draw
and it seems the most legitimate several
other things to know or that endure the
titular character mention that Odin was
the one who sent him to earth and with
the Bifrost destroyed he is unable to
return however once the tesseract is
back in the possession of Asgard at the
end of Avengers the Bifrost becomes
fixed which signifies that Odin was able
to harness the power of the space stone
within it and two days prior knowledge
of its usage able to rebuild the buy
from us as with all fan theories it's
great to hear discussions from fans and
experts alike so if you have your own
theories on this please comment below
and let me know I'd love to hear from
you and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content that analyzes
film comics TV and games weekly and
they'll definitely be something on here
that you love I recently discussed the
ending of Jurassic world fallen Kingdom
as well as what direction I think the
sequels were going so make sure you
check that out next or add it to you
watch later list if you haven't seen the
film yet once again thanks very much for
taking the time out to watch this and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]